hi there uh another one on ukraine here
busy weekend
hockey tournament for my old timers
hockey team we played friday night
saturday morning at nine saturday
evening at five
sorry thursday night
friday morning friday night and now
we're in the final which starts in a few
hours the body's a little bit stiff
we lost the first game and won the next
two so we're in the final
uh language in ukraine
um
big issue there is the status of the
russian language
i cannot to me
if i were a ukrainian
i would want to have two official
languages ukrainian and russian
i understand that the
people who want to build up a stronger
sense of
ukrainian identity
want to use the language as a tool for
doing this
and a lot of their actions and attitudes
when i listen to
politicians from western ukraine
ukrainian speaking
remind me of quebec catalunya
and wherever vast countries wherever
language becomes involved in politics
uh but if we go to the ukraine
uh
i think the feeling in western ukraine
which has i mean western ukraine largely
ukrainian speaking eastern ukraine
largely russian speaking
western ukraine formerly part of
polish lithuania whatever kingdom
part of the austro-hungarian empire part
of poland very different history eastern
ukraine
part of czarist russia
part of the soviet union
for a much longer time than the western
ukraine different history
different language
of course many people in eastern ukraine
uh are also speakers of ukrainian either
as a first language or as a second
language uh people in western ukraine
all from what i can gather just about
everybody speaks russian very well
uh
the concern i think on the part of the
western ukrainians is if we don't quote
force people to
learn russian excuse me learn ukrainian
then we will be watering down our
national identity and we
risk being flooded by the much more
powerful russian language
but
if half the population roughly whatever
the number is
uh has russian as their native mother
tongue spoken by their parents and
grandparents
and if those people consider themselves
to be ukrainian which i gather is the
case with most of the people even in the
eastern ukraine the number who want to
join russia is
even in the present circumstances like
30
no more
therefore
to me
that language should be recognized
and the id you know right now the the
government in kiev is saying well we'll
we now have this law that wherever the
local population exceeds whatever it is
10 then their language will be
considered official within that region
but to my mind that's not a good
solution and then of course the
government in kiev says
you know russian and or whatever
hungarian romanian sort of trying to
uh
equate the status of russian with the
status of these other or bulgarian or
languages spoken by very very few people
in ukraine
and i mean if it were me
you know when i as i said earlier
first of all i said in my first video
that the new government began by
changing the
language law that allowed this official
status for minority languages
ver and i said at that time are these
people completely stupid their economy
is a shambles their country is disunited
and the first thing they do is to
challenge the
language status of
what's as as an important a language in
ukraine as ukrainian
not very smart
the president torchinoff vetoed it fine
but the damage is done and now that's
being used all the time by the russians
by the party of regions people as
another stick with which to hit the
government
in kiev
uh now they're saying well we'll restore
that
um
or they're saying you know we'll allow
the the other part of it is this whole
autonomy or federalization or whatever
they call it and so the suggestion is if
if eastern ukraine is primarily russian
speaking then uh russian could be
official in eastern ukraine
um i think there's dangers with that and
i listened to an interview on echo musk
v
with boris
boris boris boris kalesnikov
who strikes me as an extremely
reasonable person amongst all of these
flamboyant orators in ukraine whether
uh from the west or from the east you
know fiery language
he just sounded like a voice of reason
and he said
that
russian and ukrainian should be official
across the country
in level
in
donetsk if you can't speak russian and
ukrainian you can't work for the
government
he also raised the issue that i had
raised earlier
when i first listened to an interview
again at echo must be where um
what's his name benedict of alexa
benedictof interviewed the new ukrainian
education minister who said in our
universities we have two languages
english and ukrainian and i said to
myself well that's ridiculous uh if i'm
a russian-speaking ukrainian
from donetsk
and i can't take and he's granted we
have elementary and high school in
russian but when i go to university i
have to take my engineering course my
medical
legal whatever in ukrainian i can't take
it in russia to me that's just not fair
they can offer and probably should offer
courses
in both russian and ukrainian both in le
wolfe levif and in donetsk or in lugarsk
but it should be available and similarly
all government offices including in
ivano frankevska or whatever it might be
uh government services should be
available
in fra in the french and english like at
home in ukrainian and russia
so that the whole country becomes
bilingual to me uh that because one of
the move senses you get when i watch for
example
schuster live
is the tremendous amount of
between the western ukrainians largely
ukrainian speaking and the eastern
ukrainians they both seem to want to
show this great contempt for the other
side
uh
they're not moderate they're not looking
for common ground even though they say
they are
in in one moment they'll say we've got
to find a common ground we've got to
have a dialogue and then they'll launch
off into this tirade and i find the
ukrainians
on both sides
they will never use
10 words to say something they will use
a hundred words like i got the message
and then over and over and over again
and so that all of this inflammatory
rhetoric
uh in that sense the person who
impressed me the most the other night on
schuster live was our friend the
heavyweight boxer
uh klitschko
vitaly klitschko he's he's not a great
speaker he's not a fiery speaker good
for him i'm tired of hearing timoshenko
i'm tired of hearing whatever this other
fellow was from the party of regions and
and especially the the you know
tsarioff and dubkin and they all seem so
so angry and so cynical and uh
and uh we need people with just kind of
and i i by that same token i find
poroshenko uh
you know relaxing to listen to and i
think and this fellow here what was his
name again kolesnikov boris kolesnikov
calm down the rhetoric
find some common ground
and so on the issue of language
uh and the other advantage of that is if
you have western ukrainians ukrainian
speaking eastern ukraine is
russian-speaking you're basically
dividing the country
you should have in my opinion as a
foreigner two official languages across
the whole country and lots of exchange
another thing that impressed me with
boris kalestinkov is one of the earliest
sessions of schuster live that i watched
was one where they had
various
i guess they always have uh you know
deputies from the radha they were party
regions which part of regions is
basically yanukovych's party pro-russian
they got kicked out largely because of
the
the maidan and the events that occurred
there and so now they are kind of using
the violence in eastern ukraine kind of
as a bit of a horse that they can ride
to get back into power
the whole thing there's like so many
different levels of plots and subplots
uh but anyway at this uh
particular meeting in addition to the
normal politicians haranguing each other
they had uh some students
and uh
the don bass or donetsk hockey team
in the khl russian hockey league
um
had organized this exchange of students
from donetsk and life and they had
exchange
and they even had
a former
nhl hockey player a ukrainian
fedenco as we called them fedotinca
there he wasn't very interested in
talking politics
but obviously this was organized by the
donetsk hockey team by mr boris
kolesnikov so the minute i heard the
interview there and this is
the president of the dennis hockey team
and he's also a man who organized the
euro 2012 events uh in ukraine which
apparently were done very successfully
he's a self-made he's again one of these
wealthy oligarchs but he didn't make his
money by
stealing state assets from what i can
tell he's a private businessman a
successful one i don't know who knows
i was impressed by him and i think if
people like him
and poroshenko and klitschko
talk more and some of the more
you know inflammatory guys like sobelief
on the uh
whatever it's called party or even
timoshenko with all her constant uh you
know jean-dark
imagery
uh then there might be some hope so here
you have it on language which is
something i'm interested in and it's not
a matter of learning it because from
what i can gather first of all ukrainian
is so similar to russian
uh
and right now i'm trying to learn
ukrainian so i can understand what these
western ukrainian politicians are saying
and what i do is i read stuff on the
ukrainian newspaper
and
i take it copy it
now rather than putting it into google
translate which i have been doing i'm
taking it into link i'm using the hebrew
slot because i'm not planning to study
hebrew anytime soon
and then i use
google translate and of course each time
i go to google translate i have to
change the language to ukrainian because
i'm in the hebrew slot it wants to go to
hebrew but uh so it's a little more time
consuming but i i can actually start
building up
uh uh you know a series of lessons now
in ukrainian where i'm gradually
converting these words into
words that i can understand rereading
them again looking at my yellow links
and each time i do it i pick up a few
more words and so each time i listen to
uh shuster live and i listen to the
ukrainians i understand more and more of
what they're saying so that's kind of
fun for me to use my interest in the
events in ukraine
as a sort of
a motivator for learning ukrainian but
as a foreigner
no no dog in the fight as they say
i think that ukraine the kiev government
should just come out and say we have two
official languages across the whole
country just as mr boris kolesnikov
owner of the dom